[Music]
today's question comes from brody in
alaska i'm an 18 year old entrepreneur
and i'm starting college this fall i
started a residential painting company a
few months ago we paint exteriors and
interiors and the business has really
taken off quickly i have one full-time
employee and our success has been so
great that we're turning down work my
take-home pay is 1800 per week could you
give me some advice on how to grow my
business quickly without burning myself
out well i'll tell you dave the thing
that jumps out to me about this question
is the fact that he's 18 year old 18
years old about to start college so to
me that changes the answer a little bit
because you're about to become a student
whereas if this was your full-time gig
you're 30 years old and you just want to
grow it okay we could talk about
increasing your prices we could talk
about hiring more staff
and scaling in that way
but but for brody i mean your a1 is
being a student so it's not that we're
going to ignore the business i know a
lot of college students that have a
business in addition to being a student
i just wouldn't make that your top
priority where you're sacrificing um
attending classes or doing homework
because you're trying to lead a huge
staff team i don't think that that's the
right priority at this at this stage
yeah if the only thing you do is make
ninety thousand dollars a year
brody that was pretty ambitious right
there
you don't have to add ambition on top of
that we're pretty impressed already dude
you're freaking 18 years old you're
making 1800 bucks a week take home pay
yeah yeah so seriously that's pretty
impressive i don't think we grow this
business i i would i would grow it only
enough to maintain it yep um and and
let's get through four years of school
and
then maybe you go back and teach
business at that college after you're
done oh my gosh
because most of your professors in the
business category have never made 1800 a
week and they're running their own
business
so um there you go wow that's impressive
i love questions like that what a kid
man what a kid i love it all right